[Música]
tudo bem pessoal não tem como falar da
minha profissão da minha vida
profissional sem falar da minha roupa
óbvio né
e eu vou contar para vocês um pouquinho
do do que foi essa história do piano
tá aqui eu quero dizer que é doce néia
tudo isso que ela contou que muito mais
né
e ela vai vai me ajudar aqui um
pouquinho nesse dia que me convidaram
para fazer um bom dia paraná era um
assunto horroroso que é consórcio
consórcio é um tema difícil tal e
acordei sei lá três horas da manhã na
praça estudar porque eu sabia que eu ia
fazer aquelas perguntas sim muito
difíceis e as perguntas eram ao vivo
falei meu deus só falou uma bobagem né
e lá fui eu claro que eu tava de xadrez
óbvio né
a minha camisa xadrez é uma camisa
vermelha isso foi em julho de selagem
2017 pronto eu chego lá no estúdio do se
não não a entrevista não era para ser no
estúdio e foi no estúdio como foi no
estúdio eu estava com uma camisa xadrez
até aí tudo bem só que estava com uma
calça que de quadradinho eu estava com
uma meia listrada e naquele dia estava
muito over mesmo estava bem estranho
mesmo aquele dia mais estranho do que
normalmente mas como eu achei que ia ser
só daqui pra cima não me incomodei foi
enfim lá fui eu
aí foi deu entrevista foi uma quinta
feira no sábado uma pessoa de maringá eu
acho que lá uma cidade que traz a
curitiba me faz uma crítica no facebook
horrorosa
assim é como que uma diretora de uma de
uma enfim do órgão público pode se
vestir dessa forma que é ridículo mas a
mulher detonou
eu estava falando foi no sábado eu vi
isso como ela fez um aberto no facebook
também me senti à vontade por respondeu
alberto né
então mas eu não respondo com fígado e
essa é a primeira coisa que eu queria
falar pra vocês é algo que eu aprendi a
nunca ou pelo menos né tentar nunca
responder com o fígado porque se você
responde com o fígado
você vai dar a pior resposta possível
uma hora fazendo uma resposta de cinco
linhas uma hora
sentada no carro na hora de fazer
artesanato eu tinha de comprar material
para fazer artesanato estava no
estacionamento da loja uma mas mais de
uma hora que fique louca na hora falei
meu deus né como é que a pessoa fala
isso pra mim foi muito ofensivo foi
horrível
aí eu fiz mandei pra ana ana jornalista
me ajuda muito né
fabiana é a minha companheira a
jornalista porque ela me ajuda muito
não que ela me acompanha e aí eu falei
assim ana lê pra mim
daí ela leu falar um toque pode mandar
isso foi na no sábado a entrevista tinha
sido na quinta
na segunda feira eu sou uma pessoa de
hábitos
eu tomo café todo dia no mesmo lugar uma
panificadora lá né na padaria lá do alto
aqui estava lá tomando meu café chega um
cara que trabalha com um consórcio com
esses cara muito bom de tudo bem tudo
bem né tipo tudo bem tudo bem e que era
tudo bom um tipo meio um lindo assim né
e eu falei vou escutar eu vi a
entrevista que concedeu à frente puxa eu
falei uma bobagem porque o tema é um
tema difícil na ele não as respostas
foram perfeitas inclusive a gente
colocou entrevista num grupo quis que o
grupo lá da galera aquele que em quem
trabalha com consórcios
ele me mostrou mas ele não mostrava o
telefone assim ele mostrava meio assim e
eu vim aqui uma foto minha rolava ali
naquela coisa só nossa é também não
liguei o que era né isso na segunda
feira e na terça feira eu virei n
por conta daquela foto né que eu tô
parecendo garibaldo a cheia de listra
camiseta
enfim eu virei um superman quem foi para
facebook o troço e começou bem como na
época era presidente de uma associação
que representa os procons do país e
beleza né eu falei bom a gente a galera
me ligando famosa tipo não aquele nossa
engraçadão assim sabe que roupa exagerou
na roupa que os procons no espírito
santo estava sabendo da história porque
eu virei meme no facebook
e aí beleza né o que eu fiz foi fazer da
minha vida respondeu com fita
talvez fosse uma opção eu poderia ter
respondido com fígado poderia ter dito
olha eu mesmo dia que eu quiser você não
tem nada a ver com isso quem eu sou dona
da minha vida cheguei a uma idade que eu
posso me vestido que eu quiser
isso tudo é verdade mas eu não poderia
responder isso de uma forma agressiva e
eu também não poderia falar isso sem
vincular com o meu trabalho que não tem
sentido que minha roupa e qual é a coisa
menos importante do universo na
importância tem a minha roupa é ridícula
talvez em alguns momentos seja é
completamente fora do que as pessoas
normalmente utilizam super por exemplo
dos eu jamais vi time estiver com essa
classe que você tivesse eu não sei fazer
isso pois então tapioca doce - vai ser
copiada então eu não tenho essa essa eu
não consigo eu acho bonito colorido eu
acho o show cara super chique
eu gosto de coisas coloridas mas aí eu
vou contar pra vocês antes de contar o
final da história porque eu gosto tanto
de coisas coloridas e porque na minha
vida que não tem nada a ver com o meu
trabalho mas tem tudo a ver com o meu
trabalho
a roupa colorida faz tanto sentido
porque a roupa pra mim é um ambiente de
liberdade de errar é onde eu me sinto
livre e eu fiquei presa durante 12 anos
a uma doença a doença da minha mãe minha
mãe morreu como uma criança
eu tive que nesse tinha que ter um
momento de liberdade que a roupa era a
roupa foi o que me salvou o procon foi o
que me salvou
quantas vezes doce a gente se encontrou
eu tinha que correndo embora
gente eu deixei minha mãe sozinha não dá
tem que mora as entrevistas eram todas
comigo no bom dia pra no mesmo lugar
porque era um lugar onde eu podia voltar
correndo para casa então eu tinha que
ter um lugar onde pudesse ser livre
só uma coisa o relógio está andando para
frente e também no tratado não sei
quanto tempo eu tenho para falar com
alguém que ajuda não tava 22h 30 não o
contrário
falar que eu tinha 18 minutos aumentando
para 30 na né
eu tenho até 10.000 beleza não se falava
em casa é tão estranho isso
e aí voltando então a roupa pra mim onde
eu podia e posso ser livre é o mesmo do
jeito que eu quiser não é maravilhoso
isso é sensacional
pronto não é pra todo mundo e não
poderia ser uma moça
eu sou bem bonita para ser o moça não me
aceitar e eu estou a falar com elas são
lindas ou xix aquelas roupas são super
bonita aquela que o chapeuzinho coxa
super bacana mas não é pra mim aquilo
então eu trabalho o meu trabalho me
permite que eu me visto dessa forma o
que é muito bom né
então se uma pessoa de sorte e voltando
à questão do doping jama tava lavando
utilizada com a história da mulher que
chama de descaso no facebook que essas
coisas atingem a gente eu disse a vocês
você pode dizer que a minha roupa é
ridículo não tem problema não se
defender para isso disse claudia não
está legal também exagerada do tipo eu
viajei com uma colega de trabalho uma
vez ela era bem espalhafatosos e mais um
pela famosa chique
não é porque se viu tão neutro h porque
não a gente chega em brasília parecendo
uma escola de samba
eu falei não então é isabel trabalha
comigo ela falou isso vai ficar com a
gente em brasília pela escola de samba
vai dar né
foi uma beleza então fechou eu mais pra
escola de samba menos vazada
pronto e aí essa história toda né que
virou meme tal eu tenho que dar uma
resposta para isso
em resposta que eu dei eu dei a resposta
que que é importante importante para as
pessoas a quem eu sirvo porque eu sou
uma servidora pública com orgulho o
senhor eu tenho muito orgulho de ser
servidora ser servidor é a coisa mais
legal da minha vida eu adoro procon
eu acho eu aprendi um pouco sobre zados
né
eu acho que o serviço público não pode
ser algo carro culto que vem cercando
kudo não pode ser legal que a gente não
pode acolher as pessoas falarem
acolhimento aqui porque eu não posso
acolher o consumidor colocar no lugar do
outro saber que ele pode contar com a
gente sabe que ele pode que a reclamação
dele podia me perguntaram quanto à
reclamação bizarra de um consumidor
nenhuma reclamação de nenhum consumidor
é bizarro que fecha a cara não me faça
mais perguntas desse jeito porque porque
para aquele consumidor
aquela reclamação é a coisa mais
importante da vida dele e eu como
servidora têm o dever de ajudar a
resolver essa reclamação desse
consumidor
aí eu aproveitei aquela história na do
pijama
a história ficou meio e virou até frio e
tal a diretora do procon vai dar
entrevista 6 horas da manhã e pijama
eu pretendo responder poderia ter
respondido com fígado eu resolvi não
responder com o fígado
eu não sou uma pessoa que tenha boas
idéias uma pessoa criativa mas aquela
foi a melhor ideia que não vou ter na
minha vida igual àquela eu peguei o meu
amigo sentar comigo advogado que cuida
do meu lado rafael e rafa brincar é um
filme que ele foi fazer né
eu falei assim é e hoje eu tenho uma
resposta para você consumidor que anda
por aí dizendo que minha roupa parece
que chama se eu posso trabalhar de
pijama você consumidor pode reclamar de
pijama como mostra para eles por favor
do consumidor ponto gov.br
eu acho que a única coisa que eu sei
falar na minha vida se você me encontrar
na rua etc oi tudo bem vocês ficam à
disposição 24 horas porque porque é isso
né porque o pai
público estado enfim eu quando o
servidor e agora como gestora pública
nós temos o dever de levar para o
cidadão ferramentas resolva a sua vida
eu entro no procon todo dia se eu fizer
uma conta a gente tem dados sobre isso é
selar a 50 por cento das reclamações que
a gente recebe são em relação operadoras
de telefonia o banco ou seja situações
que poderiam ser resolvidas através do
consumidor com love
isso quer dizer que um cidadão
paranaense que um cidadão aqui de
curitiba não precisa gastar dinheiro de
ônibus para ir até lá porque o dinheiro
caro para as pessoas é o dinheiro que
ele tira de outra coisa para fazer uma
reclamação que um fornecedor não
resolveu ele pode fazer a reclamação
através do consumidor ponto gov
então o meu o meu empenho maior
diariamente é fazer essa ferramenta
chegar na mão das pessoas é botar na
bancada bota não tenho no seu celular
tem aplicativo consumidor quanto gov
resolve a vida é superlegal funciona aí
sempre tem o cara chato né
sabe você é bonito pra caramba meus e
passou por mim eu tenho que falar isso
se passou por mim eu falei meu deus que
homem bonito rapaz eu não sabia que ele
era seu filho dos falei cara do celso é
bonito você faz filho porém também né
e aí o que acontece o cara chega e fazer
uma reclamação contra a operadora de
telefonia vai pro consumidor do mundo
bob mandou o cara chato diz assim ah mas
é preciso reclamar contra a casa das
bolinhas à casa das bolinhas não está no
consumidor ponto gov
aí eu pego fígado um quarto ele e digo
então o caso das bolinhas não é um
grande ofensor
em termos de quantidade use os outros
serviços do procon paraná oferece
mas nós temos um consumidor ponto gov
mais de 500 empresas
é possível que atua reclamação não seja
contra uma delas né
quando a gente fez a prospecção para as
empresas aderirem ao consumidor ponto
org que a adesão espontânea então se
tiver alguém que represente empresa por
favor faça adesão participe é muito
legal é um contato tem um outro cliente
é você que o cliente ainda a gente
uma galera do boticário aderir e aí vem
um cara que não esqueço nunca do cinema
chamado alan kardec até o nome do cara
iluminado - aí o cara disse sim pra mim
é que as pessoas ficam meio assim errado
vai entender 14 anos e mais outro
advogado ak aaa mas eu não quero me
expor eu digo não existe não se expor
hoje meu filho
se você faz alguma bobagem o consumidor
vai pras redes sociais vai detonar
então use que mais oficiais para
resolver conflito porque a vida é essa
né
você pode escolher a melhor forma o pior
forma escolha a melhor forma e aí o cara
do boticário diz assim olha que ele
começou a falar posso fazer uma pergunta
fifa e assim o cara vai vim com maré não
sei se a gente vai ver
vamos internalizar eu já cansei do vício
vamos internalizar vamos falar com o
jurídico o presidente com deus que o
papa está pronto o cara diz assim pra
mim posso dizer que eu sou a primeira
empresa que no pará madrid dá vontade de
ver que me dá um beijo e um abraço
e aí o que eu vou dizer para vocês
porque eles são o que eles são
gente vamos lá boticário transformou
sabonete em presentes o gol de gênio
ela é você não vai comprar você moço que
a condutora você não vai comprar um
looks luxo para dar de presente pra ela
mas vai comprar um não-jogo do boticário
sabonete desodorante
durante anos a estátua da mas um creme
um negócio assim ela não é isso não é à
toa que as pessoas são geniais
não é à toa que as pessoas diferenciam
na no mercado e eu acho que é isso então
terminou meu tempo aqui eu só quero
dizer pra vocês usem abusem e divulguem
o consumidor ponto gov.br
é um serviço público gratuito para todos
os consumidores deste país não é só para
macaé para o país todo então fala porque
os vizinhos parentes que moram longe
conta hoje a cara baixa o aplicativo e
faz a reclamação resolve a vida
muito obrigado